all right and so this is a very very
real world tactical
um tidbit that you can use to close
[Music]
sales
i want to give you a quick and tactical
uh training this is one of my favorite
stories of all time from selling
stuff and this comes from the
vaults of richard schwartz and manos
swords furriers
they're a fourth generation furrier in
baltimore
and they took over the entire market
really the larger like maryland
pennsylvania market
just simply doing the boring work and
being better at the everyday things and
so
richard schwartz unknowing unbeknownst
to him was a a mentor of mine in terms
of
i just observed a lot of the things that
he did in his business
and i started doing back of napkin math
when i was 17 or 18 and i was like
dude this guy kills it um and he was
and i probably still is um and uh there
was one he's
i learned so many things from him but
one of them
uh was getting people to say no to say
yes
all right and so this is a very very
real world tactical
um tidbit that you can use to close
sales
now there's a specific type of sale that
this really applies to which is
a lot of times bolt-on or upsells right
and these upsells can be incredibly
important to the business in terms of
driving bottom-line profit
liquidating acquisition costs and so
usually these are sales that are not
complex sales
these are not necessarily core offer
sales
these are sales uh you know within the
finish world that might be attributed to
supplement sales or meal sales or if you
were in retail it'd be like
getting someone to buy a scarf with the
outfit or um
just you know anything along those lines
you know getting someone to buy
orthotics if you're in the in the
physical therapy space or if you're in
the dental space getting to buy a
special kind of extra brace or
special toothpaste or whatever or if
you're in the beauty space
you know night serums that go with your
service package whatever it is right
the point is is that usually there's
going to be you know one or multiple
things you're going to want to go with
your core offer
all right the reason that this this
little trick i learned from him is so
powerful
is that it closes like crazy all right
so if you're used to having like 20 30
percent of people take up sales that is
a normal amount where people take up
sales
and the reason he gets 90 plus to take
his upsells because they don't know
they're being sold
all right and so here's the trick and
here's how it works and i mean
you can take this to the bank like it
works okay
and i'll give you the example uh that
they used uh at
mano and so somebody would come in and
so every year if you bought a fur coat
you would have to
store it right and they made they killed
it on storage but anyways
so people would come in so basically
they'd sell someone a car essentially
because that's how much a you know a fur
coat is
they sell someone a car and then uh
every year they would maintain that
customer relationship by getting them to
come back in and store their coat
uh during the summer because it's not
good to you know keep a really expensive
fur
in uh you know the heat or whatever
right that's at least part of the pitch
and so uh everybody brings their fur in
to get stored in condition so they brush
them
you know and i was one of the guys who
was brushing them in the fricking
warehouse and like spraying these things
down
uh it was my numbing work but i got to
learn a lot while i was there
and so anyhow uh we brushed these coats
and
so one of the one of the things one of
the promotions you ran as an incentive
was get a free pair of uh
fur earmuffs uh when you store your coat
for winter
or your cup for summer excuse me and so
tons of people would come in because
they wanted these
true real fur uh earmuffs
by bringing it in and so what ended up
happening is david his son
would uh the person would come in and
they'd say i want to
i would want to do this and can i get
the the fur for emotes and so he would
show them the free ear muffs
and then say well um you're
like what we're going to do is uh store
and condition your coat you don't want
anything else do you
uh and they would say no i don't want
anything else but the conditioning was
an upsell
right and it's almost even the way i
presented issues now it's like well
you're going to store in your condition
your code
but storing code versus storing and
doing the brush down and doing the
uh the shampooing of the coat is
obviously an extra service but it
immediately added a couple hundred bucks
to every
single coat and they were doing
thousands of codes right
and so anyhow uh the point is is that
they would get people to just
agree that they don't want anything else
okay
so think about how you can use this
strategy right there's there's
there's many ways you can use it but the
something else is the easiest that i can
ever see
right so let's say you say hey like this
is what you're gonna
uh this is what you need to take uh for
this weight loss program right these are
the four supplements you need to take
now you might have more supplements
right and you're like
you don't want to buy anything else do
you right and then they're going to
automatically a lot of times like you
don't want to buy any more stuff do you
and then they're like no no i don't want
to get anything else right and by doing
that you automatically close
the sale that you just recommended right
and you can do the same thing
uh in a different way which would be
like um
hey uh you don't want to pay full retail
for that right and they're going to be
like no no i don't
it's like cool so you want me to send it
uh with this discount to the you know
the address i have on file and they'll
be like okay yeah let's do that
right and so by doing that you're
getting them to say uh
yes by saying no and the thing is is
people are so contrarian people
always feel like they're being sold that
you actually use that
psychological like it's subconscious
like they can't even think
they're not even making the thought
process like they're agreeing
because they're so pre-programmed to try
not to buy things that they end up
buying things and so you use that
psychological bias to your advantage
it's one of the most powerful
techniques i have ever seen in sales
most people get 20 to 30
uptake on their uh upsells
if you use an assume close tactic like
this
you can literally see 90 plus take rates
on this
right and so as a as to to wrap up the
story
um when uh they give them the earmuffs
at the
at the furrier they would
they would they would say well now that
you have those uh you're gonna need to
to store those
and condition those as well so that'll
be you know an extra whatever
and so it ended up happening is that
people would get the the free uh the
free earmuffs
but you'd have to pay to get a story to
conditions which would cover the cost of
so uh it was just kind of hilarious
because what ended up happening is he'd
give it to them they'd have it in their
hand and be like well
you still need to store it because you
just brought your coat here and you're
not going to keep these out so to be
to be congruent with the story of of
needing to store the coats
they had to wrap it right underneath the
jacket and they would take both of them
into the back and so people would come
in
they'd get the ear muffs they'd hold on
to them and they put them right back on
their coat and they say hey you don't
want us to
do anything else besides you know
storing and conditioning do you and
they're like no no i don't know anything
else like okay cool well let's
get that taken care of and then they'd
expect the code real fast like i want to
take care of this button it's kind of
loose want us to
sew this little seam here and be like
yeah sure you want anything else to be
right no no
and so every time each one of these
things they just keep upselling them
but people are so subconsciously wired
to try and say no to upsells
that they would say yes by saying no and
so
you can try and utilize that in your
business i think it works very well with
kind of like hand-to-hand small
upsells but a lot of these little small
upsells can be massive
profit drivers in the business this is
kind of like your fries and coke
situation that i'm talking about here
like this is
a lot like you don't make your money on
the burger you make your money on the
fries in the cup because there's the
high profit margin things even though
it's not the core offer
and a lot of times there's huge pockets
of profit that most especially most
small
business owners especially if you're
running like a brick and mortar uh
service business uh that you're missing
out on so um
highly recommend using that strategy if
you're like oh man i wish i could use it
in my business
you can just use your brain and be
creative because
uh winners always think man i wonder how
i could use that in my business and
losers think that wouldn't work in my
business my business is different
so decide which one you are and then
execute accordingly
otherwise lots of love hope you guys
have an amazing saturday hope that was
value for you if it is
you know drop or tag or like or do all
the the fun stuff
and uh i hope to see you on the next
podcast all right
catch you soon bye
[Music]
you